[music playing]
KATIE COURIC: If the
battle over monuments
has been raging in towns
across the country,
the early skirmishes started
at Ivy League universities
like Yale.
CROWD: Hey hey!
Ho ho!
Calhoun's College has to go.
Hey hey!
Ho ho!
Calhoun's College has to go.
KATIE COURIC: Calhoun College
was named in 1933 after Yale
alumnus John C. Calhoun, a
senator from South Carolina who
later served as vice
president to John Quincy
Adams and Andrew Jackson.
But that's not all.
In the first half
of the 19th century,
he was the most strident
articulator, to use his words,
of slavery as a positive good.
And he rooted that
view that slavery
was a positive both for
slave holders and slaves,
an idea that--
that-- that I think is deeply
disturbing to us today.
He rooted that belief in core
beliefs about white supremacy.
KATIE COURIC: Senior Dasia
Moore said Calhoun's name
and the images from his
time made her uncomfortable,
especially in the dining hall.
Right across
from me, I can see
this stained glass
window that depicts
two slaves picking something.
It's a symbol that declares,
you do not belong here,
or you are imagined
in this space
to fulfill a certain
really limited role.
KATIE COURIC: The
already simmering debate
became more heated
after Yale dining
hall worker Corey Menafee
smashed one of the windows.
REPORTER: Although a university
worker for eight years,
Menafee says he had been
working in the dining hall
at Calhoun College
for just six months.
While mopping the floors, the
38-year-old took a mop handle
to the subject of his disgust.
KATIE COURIC: What was going
through your head, Corey?
I was--
I was just sick of
looking at that window.
Here we are in the 21st
century, and I don't think
those type of images should
be blatantly displayed
in places like dining halls.
It's culturally insensitive.
It's no secret that the
majority of the employees
who work in the dining hall are
of African-American descent.
KATIE COURIC: It was a literal
and figurative breaking point.
WOMAN (ON BULLHORN): Take down
these racist window panes.
CROWD: Change the name.
KATIE COURIC: Yale President
Peter Salovey was initially
opposed to changing the name.
Our campus, both
in the classroom
but also outside
of the classroom,
it is a living history lesson.
And I wanted to make sure that
that conversation about Calhoun
was one that we
could always have.
MAN (ON BULLHORN): Calhoun
does not deserve [inaudible]..
CROWD: Change the name.
KATIE COURIC: Salovey was caught
between students who thought
his decision was
wrong-headed, and older
alumni who felt he should
stand on the side of tradition.
So Salovey appointed a committee
to come up with a blueprint
for who stays and who goes.
After all, nine other
buildings on campus
are named for men
associated with slavery,
including Elihu Yale himself.
John Witt was head
of the committee.
Renaming ought to be a rare
thing on a research university
campus like ours, but sometimes
renaming might be appropriate.
We're supposed to think
abstractly about principle
legacies, thinking about
whether the idea is
contested at the
time of the namesake,
thinking about what the
motive of the university
was in putting the
name on the building.
And then last, how
does the building work
in helping to build community.
KATIE COURIC: The committee
came up with four principles
and discovered Calhoun's
name was controversial even
back in 1933.
There were statements written
at the time saying, really?
John C. Calhoun?
KATIE COURIC: So at
a ceremony this fall,
Calhoun College was
officially renamed
after the late Navy
Admiral, computer pioneer,
and Yale alumna, Grace Hopper.
Bless those that belong
to this college now.
Grace Marie Hopper is your home.
Was it emotional for
you, Dasia, in there?
It was.
I mean, I--
I got hit with the emotion
right before I walked in,
and it was just pure joy.
Well, I was really excited
about it, because I've always
looked up to Grace Hopper
ever since I learned
about her in high school.
So now when people ask
you what college you're in--
I'm really excited to
tell them I'm in Hopper.
I'm really proud to be
here as a sophomore.
Changing the
people that we honor,
um, helps a wider
range of students
be able to envision
themselves as someone
who can make a difference,
who will be remembered.
KATIE COURIC: As part
of a conscious effort
to not sanitize
or erase the past,
Calhoun's name and image
will remain on the edifice.
It's no longer the name by
which this college is known,
but the history and what we need
to learn from and about John
C. Calhoun is not wiped away.
We can't forget that Yale was
a university that once did have
a college, a very important
part of the campus,
dedicated to John C. Calhoun.